So we're doing volume one and each week we are simply continuing from last week
because this is a continuous text and they part of the text that we're actually
dealing with which is very early stage. Louisa is remembering how the Lord brought
her into this extraordinary relationship with him and she is recording the
difficulties that she had along the way. Now volumes one to four are the foundations
of the whole life in the divine will. It's like the foundations of a house.
Volume five to ten is like building the walls of the house. Volumes eleven and
twelve are like putting the roof on and all the other volumes are like changing
a house into a home and building your garden and making the whole thing
completely livable. And I always give that image because it helps you to
understand that you can't skip any volumes. There's lots of people who think I don't
need the beginning. I'm not a newcomer to the spiritual life. But the thing is
that the divine will spirituality is the crown and completion of all
spirituality so you can't come unless you have a great deal of spirituality
behind you and then you become a beginner in divine will. So this is like saying
you've done your primary school, you've done your secondary school, now you're
into the university and so you start as a beginner in the university even though
you finished in your secondary school as somebody who was completing. So this is
the highest level that Jesus says he wants to bring us to. So Louisa begins to
talk about the privation that she suffers and she really had great
difficulty with it. The privation was this is just for people who have just
joined us. You and I have to live by faith. I presume you haven't seen visions
and had revelations and all the rest of it so you wouldn't understand what
privation was. But a person who goes into very very deep prayer and has known
communion with God and has reached union with God has got used to a very very
close communion with God and if you've never tasted it you have no idea what
you're missing because one instant of it is worth ten lifetimes. I mean one
instant I'm not saying one minute, one instant of it is worth ten lifetimes.
Louisa had this 24/7 365. Not only that but the Lord was appearing to her almost
every day, initially almost every day and then it goes on to every single day and
then many times a day. Now this is so completely off the richter scale for
everybody else that we have no way of measuring the pain that she would have
because the problem is that if you see heaven you don't want earth. The reason
why the Lord doesn't show himself to us is that he wants us to have a pilgrimage
time on the earth. He sent us to the earth to learn a whole lot of lessons. I
hope you've learned them and we're supposed to get our PhD in certain
lessons. All of us have certain things we have to learn. It's a journey he has
sent us on and we must complete the journey so we all are moving and in the
divine will what he does is instead of trekking the mountains in spirituality
you then got a helicopter and if you went any higher you got an ordinary
airplane but in the divine will he actually catapults you into the sky.
It's like putting a rocket into and he brings you all to a level that nobody
else has. So if you're at this level the pain that Louisa had Jesus explains in
the higher volumes was the pain of parketry. Souls who have seen God and they
can't have him for the moment. They can't have him in fullness for the moment.
He also told her at one stage that she had experienced hell as well and that
is the total deprivation of God after you've seen him because that's actually
what hell is. Whether you describe it as fire or anything else they're only
descriptions but the real pain is that you've seen God and you cannot be
without him because you were created for him and you were created for that
extraordinary love that exists between God and each one of us. So we want to
pick up with Louisa talking about days of deprivation and she'll tell you
what this awful pain she has. You just have to accept it because you will not
have experienced it yourself. In this way she said I would spend sometimes two
days sometimes four more or less that is deprived of him as he pleased. I'm taking
up from last time. This is where I stop. What page is it for you? Sixteen. In the
book is page 16. My only comfort she said was to receive him in the sacrament.
Now this is a translation from Italian and the translator is talking as if
there's only one sacrament. So you have to put your pen through it and put the
Holy Eucharist on top because there are seven sacraments. Yes, certainly I found
him there. I couldn't doubt it. And I remember only a few times he would not
let himself be heard. So even in the deprivation she's hearing him even if
she doesn't see him. So this is a level of communion with God that the rest of
snow nothing about. She said because I prayed him and prayed him and
importumed him so much that he would make me content. Now do you hear her
saying I kept praying on till he answered. There's a very good example of
that in Luke chapter 18 the woman and the unjust judge. Do you remember? So it's
actually Luke 18. But when Jesus teaches about prayer in Luke chapter 11 he
tells you to persist. He tells you to persist. Keep at it. Because he will
explain as we go along in these volumes that very often God doesn't answer your
prayer simply because he wants you to pray it at a deeper level. You're praying
too superficially. If you've reared children you know the difference between
a child saying I want a biscuit because they've seen a packet of biscuits and a
cry where a child has real need. So you jump over anything to get them with a
real cry. Now the Lord says that one of the reasons why he doesn't answer our
prayers immediately is that the cry isn't deep enough. It's now actually coming
from our innermost being. Now our Lady in Midgory has underlined that as well and
she said pray from the heart. Pray from the heart not just from the lips. So
there's Louisa saying that she absolutely insisted until he responded.
The thing is the Lord doesn't mind you persisting in prayer. He actually likes
it because he says to himself because somebody really wants me. You know we've
got all these people saying prayers because they have to say them and here's
somebody who actually wants me. That makes a big difference doesn't it? So she
said I would spend those days in that state described above. I would feel him
come back within me especially if I had been faithful to him. Now she's
underlying something there that's actually very important. The more faithful we are
to the Lord the deeper and the better and the quicker he will respond to
anything. But it's the same with us in relationships as well. If a person is
really close to us and really faithful to us we respond pretty quick as well.
And the person is not really in good relationship with us. We're not all that
quick to respond are we? Now don't forget we are made like God and the Lord has
told me that if you want to explain things spiritually look to your own
relationships in marriage and outside of marriage and you'll get an awful lot of
the answers as to how he responds to us because we were made like him. So he
spoke to me more clearly and since during the previous days I had not been
able to conceive one word or feel anything within me because she was in
such pain. I came to know that it was not my fantasy what was going on. Now in
volume one she's trying to discern all the time is the stuff that's happening to
me really from God or not and it's very important for her to make that discernment.
As I said to myself many times before so much so that of what has been said up
here I would say nothing either to the confessor to any living soul. Now you have
to get quite far into volume one before Louisa says something very simple. I never
told my parents and she's living in the same house and she's spending most of her
day in prayer. Can you imagine the pain of the parents with a teenager
spending hours and hours and hours in their own room and the parents saying you
know she's not being sociable she's not reaching out to anybody else. So their
pain comes into this eventually because she has to deal with the parents
eventually but she's actually quite far on in her relationship with God for she
tells anybody. It's quite extraordinary. So when she says she didn't tell any
other living soul she actually means it. But I did as much as I could to we would
say respond to him but my translation always says correspond otherwise he would
wage such a war against me that I'd have no peace. Now what she's referring to
there is what we've already read in the pages before now and that is that he was
guiding her very specifically into what she was to do. Our Lord she said you've
been very good to me and I've been so bad so bad you mustn't take that on the
dictionary level she's talking about in comparison with the extraordinary love
and benevolence that's coming from God that the response that she's giving is
not good enough. That's always the way with us. So continuing what I had started
I would feel him within me I would hug him I would clasp him to myself and I
would say beloved good see how hard has been our separation and he would say to
me what you have gone through is nothing yet prepare yourself for harder trials.
Now I've read Dr. Valium 30 I haven't just got time to finish it at the
moment but believe me this is nothing to us coming but the Lord is very good he'll
always warn you he says you're only at the beginning this is nothing. This is
why I have come he said to dispose your heart and strengthen it. Now this is
extremely important that if we are to be able to open up to God in some new way
we have to be disposed we have to be ready we have to be prepared and so
he's saying to her that the experiences you're having now are actually preparing
you for what is to come and that's true of all of us. Now you will tell me
everything you've gone through your doubts and your fears and all your
difficulties so I may teach you how to behave in my absence. Now you're talking
about a teenager relating to God and so at this very early stage she he allows
her to tell him everything look like a young person talking to their father. Now
the relationship between them is going to evolve as time goes on. So what he's
saying is open your heart to me tell me everything and I will I will guide you.
So the next thing she experiences is aridity in prayer. Now do you know what
aridity in prayer is? You're doing fine and then all of a sudden one day you
wake up and you couldn't get a prayer out if you even if somebody used a
syringe to get it out you couldn't get it out you couldn't think a good thought
because your soul and therefore your mind has gone into a state that's called
aridity that's an inability to pray. Everybody gets that experience it's
terribly important to know how to handle it. The wrong thing to do is to
stop praying. So I would make him the narration of my pains or we would say I
tell him all about it. Lord you see without you I was unable to do anything
good. Now that's John 15 5. John 15 5 put it in the side. John 15 5 says without
me you can do nothing and the opposite of that you always have to put it with it
is Philippians 4.13 Philippians 4.13 and Philippians 4.13 says that I can do
all things in Christ who gives me the strength. So without him I can do nothing
with him I can do anything he wants. And those two references are needed all
over volume one. So the meditation I did it all distracted and ugly so much so
that I didn't have the courage to offer it to him in communion. That's like
saying you went down to the church to do an hour of saturation and you couldn't
think of anything not a thing. The only thing that would come into your head was
there wasn't religious. Now that's aridity and you get these awful
distractions going with it. You have to learn how to deal with it. So she said I
was unable to stay there for hours. It was not unusual for Louisa to pray for
three or four hours as a stint. As when I would feel you I saw myself alone I had
no one with whom to converse to talk. I felt completely empty. Now that's the
real aridity and prayer. You just feel you're utterly useless you can do nothing.
The pain of your absence made me feel mortal agonies. In other words she
really suffered. My nature wanted to hurry up and to escape that to escape
that pain. Now the reason why Louisa says that when when she suffers Jesus'
privation that her nature that means her body actually begins to disintegrate.
She's not actually exaggerating because she's sitting in a bed. She's doing
nothing physical. She's eating practically nothing. She's doing very
little sleep. So she's actually only maintained in life supernaturally. If the
Lord wasn't actually giving her the life she wouldn't have it. So we have that
phenomenon with people who live on the Eucharist as well. That if you don't give
them the Eucharist they would actually physically die. And the church has had
to learn that the hard way. So when Louisa says you know I'm losing my life or my
life is fading away she's actually telling the truth. My nature wanted to
hurry up and escape the pain. That means I wanted to die. More so since it seems to
me that I did nothing but waste time. And then the fear that in coming back you
might chastise me because I had not been faithful. So I didn't know what to do
and it's a very early stage and it's wonderful to hear a confession like
this out of a saint at a level that Louisa is at because we're supposed to
study this and learn so that we can move from our distractions and our
oridities to where she was because that's the reason why it's written. So it's
wonderful she's able to describe it. And then the pain that the pain because you
are offended continuously and I was unable to do those acts of
reparation that you taught me before and those visits to the most holy
sacrament for the different offenses you receive tell me then what should I have
done? And he very my book says benignly very kindly instructing me. Now he's the
teacher you see and if you put beside it he's going to give her a whole teaching
on prayer now because that's what he's looking for.
Deuteronomy 13, 32, 32, 15 and that says the Lord alone was her guide. There's so
much scripture in this whole thing it's absolutely fascinating. So Jesus is now
going to teach her about prayer and the reason why she was ordered to write it
down is that all the rest of us would learn the lessons. She got it the first
time but all the rest of us have to get it at some point. The first thing Jesus
said is you were wrong to be disturbed. Now throughout the first four volumes
Jesus says to Louisa continuously you must not be disturbed on the inside no
matter what's happening on the outside. So we all have things that can disturb
you or upset you or displease you or whatever in your daily life but if you
let it disturb you on the inside you will find that you're going to be so
disturbed you can't pray you can't calmly make decisions you can't use God's
wisdom it really really affects you. Now I've been giving spiritual directions since
1980 and when a person describes the difficulty that they're having what you
say to them is where you're upset on the outside or the inside. If you're upset
on the outside no problem that's like saying we're sitting in this house and
there's a storm outside but we're okay but if the storm is on the inside of the
house then we're all having problems because there's no escape and you're
you become part of the problem so if you allow disturbance into your soul you're
not able to make the contact with the Lord that you should be making. But you
can have a hurricane on the outside and if your soul is peaceful and still you
can continue a relationship with God no problem. Have I made that clear? That's
actually terribly important. So he said you were wrong to be disturbed. Don't you
know that I am the prince of peace. Philippians 4-7 is what I want you to
put there Philippians 4-7 where St. Paul tells us that Jesus gives us a peace that
passes all understanding and guards your heart and your mind in Christ
Jesus. Now I can tell you for all the people I know who have gone deeper and
deeper into the divine will the peace goes deeper and deeper and deeper. It's
fascinating to see it. It's beautiful. It's one of the signs that a person is
actually going deeper into the divine will. So I am the prince of peace and the
first thing I recommend is that you do not disturb the peace of the heart. Now
heart is used here in the biblical sense not in a modern sense. In a modern sense
we use the heart as a symbol of love and the Bible the heart means you're your
person. You're in your innermost being. So that's that's your interior. When in
prayer you're not able to recollect yourself I do not want you to think of
this or that. Our problem is that we try to rationalize why is it happening and
how do I get myself here and all the rest of it. How it is or how it's not
because in doing so you yourself my book says call the distraction we would say
cause cause the distraction. Instead when you find yourself in that state the
first thing you do is humble yourself. Look how simple it is to deal with it.
He says don't rationalize it. All the modern stuff that we're told to do he
says no no no don't do that. Humble yourself before God and open up to him
and he'll do everything. Isn't that fantastic? That's 2 Peter 5 9. Humble
yourself before God. It's 2 Peter 5 9. Bow before the power of God and he will
raise you up is what Peter says. So you humble yourself confessing that you
deserve these pains and placing yourself in the arms of the executioner. Now that
should be an inverted comma of course. Like a little lamb that licks the hand
that kisses it. So instead of all this rationality he says humble yourself
before God except that all of this is happening and let God take over. I think
it's a brilliant solution. I don't know about you. The same for you while seeing
yourself beaten disheartened and alone you will resign yourself to my holy
dispositions. You will thank me with all your heart and you will kiss my hand
that strikes you recognizing yourself unworthy of those pains. Now the very
first foundation stone in the spiritual life is humility. That's why you're told
to humble yourself. Then you will offer me the bitterness, the anguish and the
tedium. Now tedium is a very good word. She's sitting in a bed doing nothing. So
if if she has these problems in prayer you would die of tedium. Praying me to
accept them as a sacrifice of praise, of satisfaction for your sins and a
reparation for the offenses given to me. Now this is extremely important. The big
big thing in divine will is that we pay very little attention to ourselves and
whatever happens to us you humble yourself before God and you offer the
pain of it. Whether you caused it or somebody else caused it doesn't make any
difference. You offered the pain of it with the sufferings of Jesus which have
infinite merits and you ask the Lord to raise that up onto the divine level and
it becomes a divine thing as well as a human thing all sold past present and
future benefit. Isn't that incredible? From Adam to Zachary that's the first and
the last man. Everybody benefits and nobody benefits if you sit there and you
just rationalize and you feel rotten and then you say to yourself I'm gonna have
a drink. Nobody benefits and you don't benefit either and what the Lord
shows us in divine will is how to turn everything into divine currency is what
He calls it. That into a way of getting the absolute best result for yourself and
for everybody else. So in the divine will we do a lot of reparation. So we make
atonement. Atonement comes from three words at one meant to bring God and
creatures together. And so when you offer your pains with the sufferings of Jesus
in the divine will you can do that at an absolutely extraordinary level. So if you
do so he says your prayer will ascend before my throne like a fragrant incense
that Revelation 4 8 that prayer rises to the throne of God like incense. And it
will wound my heart. Now the word wound there is not used the way we use it in
modern English because to also wound is a negative thing. He means you touch my
heart. So write the little word touch over it. You touch my heart and you will
draw new graces and new carisms upon yourself. Now notice that not praying
for yourself and using the situation to make atonement for others in the divine
will you actually draw extraordinary grace upon yourself. But you're not
concentrating on yourself. In seeing you humble and resigned all plunged into
your nothingness the devil will not have the power to even get close. That's very
important because if you're going through a difficult time what the devil
does is to do everything he can think of to make you depressed, disheartened,
disillusioned so that you will abandon God. And so he keeps on pressing you down
down down down down and what the Lord shows us is to knock all of that off.
Whatever is happening to us that you united with the sufferings of Jesus in
the divine will for the redemption of the whole human race. And there will be
millions in heaven because of you you'll be surprised when you get there. You won't
see them now. He loves you too much let you see them now. Now plunged into
your nothingness for those of you who are really starting divine will that's a new
term for you. You see the ordinary spirituality that the church had until
the divine will spirituality was revealed. Humility was the great thing.
We know for example that on her death bed that St. Therese of this you said I
have achieved humility of heart and that was the highest level they could
get. You know what now the Lord says that in the divine will he wants you to
leave all that aside. I have a little book in there that there's 13 degrees of
humility. I got depressed after the third one. So it's still on the shelf and I'm
not offering it to you read. The Lord says leave all that behind. He says jump
into your nothingness. It's much much deeper than humility much deeper because
he said if you jump into your nothingness I am the all that creates out of
nothing. And so what you do is you throw your sins and your faults and your
difficulties and your struggles and you're absolutely everything into that
nothingness. And all you have to say is heaven here I come. It's absolutely
fantastic. He said if you go into your nothingness he said I will create. It's
not fantastic. He created the entire universe out of nothing. So if we offer
him our whole being thrown into our nothingness and all you got to do is say
it to him we don't know how to do it physically. All you have to do is say it
to him Lord I just throw myself into my nothingness. I can't solve anything. It's
grand. I'm gonna let you have complete freedom. My nothingness in your allness
which is fantastic. There's a he's got a wonderful sense of humor. I don't know
how well you know the Lord. If you know him well enough to know he is a wonderful
sense of humor you'll see some of that in Louise's writings. I think it's up in
volume 24. I was reading it with one one of the groups and he said but I want
your nothingness to be really empty. He knows us that you couldn't be doing
grand for a while and then a little bit of me me me comes in and you don't even
notice because I mean the world is so full of selfishness that a tiny bit
you hardly notice but if he really loves you he'll get at you about it so it has
to go. He's a wonderful sense of humor and you'll find him playing with Louise
as well. Yeah because it wasn't God's intention that we'd have a terrible time
on the earth. His intention was completely different and he reveals that in the
higher volumes when he tells you all about the creation of Adam and what he
did for him and how when the scripture says that God walked with Adam in the
cooler today there's this wonderful relationship that was between them and
they book of proverbs I think it is he likes to play with the children of the
earth just like a parent likes to play with their children to enjoy the the
child. So that's a wonderful teaching on prayer that he's given to her and
notice that it keeps the devil at bay. The devil needs you having a bit of
selfishness this me me meeting is really awful. I think the the selfie is at the
sign of an entire race gone in the wrong direction. Nobody will admire me I'll
admire myself and you look at the attitude in which they take photographs of
themselves and it's it's to be cried over. It's really really really sad they've
no idea. Whereas the in these writings the Lord says when I look at you I want to
see myself. There's a different subject altogether that your photograph turns up
as Christ which is really really fantastic. So there he shows you how to to use the
distractions in prayer the aridity and prayer and all the rest of it and to
keep the devil at bay the devil can't handle humility and believe me he's so
horrified at anybody going into their nothingness where he can't get at us at
all that he tries somebody else. And here is how you thought you were losing
and you make great gains. Now when you see how the Lord actually answers problems
in the divine will you realize we're in a win-win situation. Whether you're in
good times or bad times winter or summer spiritually the Lord shows you
exactly how to make divine currency out of it is fantastic. So the second point
then is Jesus says as far as communion that's holy communion is concerned we
would say in English. I do not want you to afflict yourself because you're not
able to stay there. Know that this is a shadow of the pains that I discovered in
Gethsemane. Now in these writings you're going to get an enormous amount of
teaching on the Blessed Eucharist and unholy communion and you'll be amazed
what he says. But here in the beginning we're not even touching it yet. What
happens what will happen when I make you share in the scourges the thorns and
the nails. Now we're only at the beginning of Volume 1 so Louisa has not
yet had any experience of the crucifixion so she's probably thinking in horror you
know. The thought of greater pains will make you suffer the minor pains with more
courage. So when during communion you will find yourself alone agonizing think
that I want a little bit of your company in my agony in the garden. Now to just
make a very long story short the Lord says if you're really suffering about
something you're an agony about something no matter what it is. He says kneel down
beside me and get seminy and throw your agony into mine and then ask me to lift
it up at the divine will and we will redeem the earth through it. Isn't that
fantastic? Imagine going to a counselor and paying endless amount of money and
going round and round and round and round and round talking about it where
you could be saving the human race in the meantime. So I want a little
bit of your company he says therefore place yourself near me and make a
comparison between your pains and mine. See you alone and deprived of me and I
too alone abandoned by my most faithful friends who are there sleeping. Left
alone even by my divine father and then in the midst of the most bitter pain
surrounded by snakes vipers and rabid dogs. Now these are symbols of the sins of
men which among which yours too took their part such as they seemed to devour me
alive. Now the reason why Louisa is being introduced instantly to the passion is
that one of the great things the Lord did for the church through her was that he
revealed his interior passion to Louisa before that the church only knew about
the external passion. So when we do the stations of the cross you're looking at
him on the outside when you do the hours of the passion you're joining him on the
inside and you're also co-redeeming with him which is really fantastic. This is
why he's introducing her. My heart was taken with such grips we would say felt
such pain that I felt I was under a wine press. Just the term press is used but
actually a wine press so much so that I sweated living blood. Hebrews 12-2. Tell
me when did you arrive at suffering so much therefore when you find yourself
deprived of me afflicted empty of all consolation filled with sadness and
worries and pains come close to me dry that blood of mine from me offer those
pains to me as relief for my most bitter agony by doing so you will find the way
to be able to stay with me after communion. It's not that you won't suffer
because the most bitter pain I can give to souls dear to me is to deprive them
of me. Notice he's saying it's my gift and it actually is he gets her to rise
higher and higher and higher and higher because of it. We say absence makes the
heart grow funder isn't that right? And by thinking that through your
suffering you give me a relief you will also be content now to give Jesus a
relief actually means to save souls that's the meaning of it. So he will often
come to her and just simply say give me a relief and you'd wonder on earth I
mean he's coming from heaven what relief does he need it's it's that we would
save souls for him. So the third thing then as for the visits and acts of
reparation you must know that everything I did in the course of 33 years from
when I was born up to when I died I am continuing in the Holy Eucharist that's
the sacrament of the altar. Now throughout these writings he underlines the fact
that in the Eucharist he is suffering much more than he ever suffered on
Calvary and he any going to great detail about it. So the passion is alive in our
midst therefore I want you to visit me 33 times a day how would you visit the
Lord 33 times a day? You could only do it in your mind that you say to the Lord
I want to send my guardian angel down to visit you or whatever you can't do it
physically it's not physically possible. And she was in a bed and until they put a
little altar in her room she couldn't do it either. So for it's he means to do it
in prayer honoring my years and also uniting with me in the sacrament with
my own intentions. Now his own intentions of staying with us in the Eucharist are
reparation and adoration that's why he has called the laity into adoration of
the Eucharist to join him not just to adore him to join him in adoring the
Father on behalf of the human race and to offer reparation for all the proper
worship that's not actually given to God. You will do this at all times with the
first thought of the morning fly before the tabernacle in which I am present for
love of you and visit me. Now those of you who have books containing the prayers
of Louisa and all of that you'll see her prayer to Jesus in the morning and her
good night to Jesus at night it's actually beautiful. And also the last
thought of the evening before you sleep at night before and after your meal and
so on. So it's just keep remembering him that's all. So while he was saying this
to me I saw myself all confused not knowing whether I could manage to do what
he asked and I said to him Lord I beg you to be with me until I acquired the
habit of doing them for I know that with you I can do everything that's your
Philippians 4 13 with you I can do it without you I can't. Without you what can
this miserable creature do that's John 15 5 I can't do it without you and he
kindly added yes yes I will content you when have I ever failed you I want your
good will whatever whatever you want I will give it to you. Underline the fact
that he wants your good will sometimes you can't actually accomplish something
for all kinds of reasons but he does want your good will. He wants because in the
divine will what he's asking is that we would gradually hand over our will to
him so that his will can actually govern our lives. What makes the divine will
different to all other spiritualities is that you're not just doing the will of
God you should be doing that before you came. We learn how to hand over our will
and your motto has got to be not my will but dine be done. It was his own motto
until the Lord takes over completely. So then she says after some time sometimes
with him and then deprived of him one day after communion I felt more intimately
united with him. He asked me various questions for example if I loved him if
I was ready to do what he wanted even the sacrifice of my life for love of him.
Now whenever the Lord asks you questions like this he's testing you he's trying
to get you to decide at what level you want to consecrate yourself to him and
you then tell me what you want. Now here's the test there's two wills his will
and hers and first of all you've got to decide what's in the two wills and who
is going to surrender to who. If you are ready to do what I want I too will do
what you want. There's a wonderful testimony from Padre Pio I never put
saint in front of these wonderful people because I think they're great or
without their ST. He was asked once why God had worked so many miracles through
him and his answer was I refuse him nothing and he refuses me nothing. That's
what you're talking about here I refuse him nothing and he refuses me
nothing. So that's what he says here if you're ready to do what I want I'll do
what you want why because there'll be only one will and it'll be the divine
will. But with time I understood that that way of acting is when he wants to
dispose of soul to new and heavy crosses actually it was much bigger than that
it's to get her to hand over her will to him completely that was the biggest cross.
So he knows how to draw her so close to himself with these strategies that the
soul doesn't dare to oppose what he wants. In other words as he asks he gives
you the grace to give what he's asking. So I said to him yes I love you but you
tell me yourself can I find anything more beautiful more holy more lovable
than you and then why ask me if I am ready to do what you want when it has
been so long since I delivered my will to you. You see she doesn't know
what he's getting at she said I've already given my will to you but she
doesn't realize that in actual fact we have to give it all the time until you
reach a point where it is so totally given it's not yours anymore. So in the
higher volumes you hear Louisa saying I'm in this immense sea of the divine will
and she's there's no way out absolutely no way out she's actually she has
arrived and she has arrived therefore in the condition that people are in heaven
that's why there's no way out and so Jesus has to tell her she's actually
she's actually having the same experience of the saints except that on earth you
are still allowed to suffer because in heaven you can't merit anymore and you
can't save anymore souls through your sufferings and so on but on earth you
have that privilege and I just read something today where the Lord said
that the angels envy us our ability to suffer and save souls they're not able
to do it it's not amazing we read that today and so they become very sad when we
don't seem to understand that it's a privilege and that they're more willing
to help us than we would ever ever guess so Louisa said it's a long time since I
offered my will to you but you've actually got to keep giving it you see
and so we think that saying Lord here is my will you can have it that's okay but
if he gives you new circumstances you still have to give it again because you
might want to give it in the new circumstances what is the new circumstances
for her he says I'm going to give you an experience of the crucifixion you will
have the crown of thorns you will have that are you sure but you can't be sure
ahead of time so he's trying to tell her that she has to be disposed for this
greater sacrifice that will be asked of her and Louisa said I pray to not despair
me even tearing me to pieces as long as I may give you pleasure well that's okay
until it happens being torn to pieces it's not funny I abandoned myself to you
oh Holy Spouse operate freely do with me whatever you want but give me your grace
and for by myself I am nothing and can do nothing here's Louisa giving her Fiat
FIA T it's actually very important it's a much deeper gift than she's given
before and put beside it Luke 1 38 when blessed mother gave her Fiat that
never changed now Louisa is being prepared to be not only a victim soul but
one of the most major of the victim souls of the 20th century and so Jesus
repeated to me are you truly ready for anything I want beside that I have put
one Peter 119 are you truly ready I saw myself more confused annihilated the
word annihilated there we would say humiliated and I said yes I am ready but
of course I was almost trembling she said and he compassionating me is the
word in my book is that in yours as well sympathizing with me this one we would
say continue to tell me don't fear I will be your strength now if you go into
the Bible you'll find that anytime the Lord calls somebody to be a special
friend or a disciple or an apostle or a prophet or anything else he always says
I will be with you and I will be your strength I will never leave you so just
want to give you a couple of references there Sam 28 verse 7 Sam 28 verse 7
Sam 46 verse 1 and Sam 73 verse 26 so Sam 28 Sam 46 Sam 73 so do not fear I
will be your strength now that means interior strength it's not to do it
physical strength it's not you that will suffer but I myself will suffer and
fight within you that is the extremely important thing that the Lord is not
just asking you to do something by yourself he's asking you to let him do
it within you that he will live his life and mission in us and through us and
that's an extraordinary privilege see I want to purify your soul from even the
slightest spot that might hinder my love within you now she's being prepared
to be a victim soul and if you know anything about what the the Old Testament
teaches about victims they had to be absolutely pure and spotless to be worthy
of God so victim souls have to be purified in a way that you and I would
find frightening and that purification is going to go on and on and on throughout
these volumes I want to test your faithfulness now whenever God truly calls a
person as well he always tests their faithfulness because if we're not going
to be faithful under all circumstances where he's not going to get anywhere
with us but how can I see if this is true other than by placing you in the
middle of a battle now Louisa has no idea what he's going to talk about he's he's
he's going to throw her into a battle with demons into a war she couldn't even
imagine and she has to win the war she has to learn how to deal with demons
because she's going to be a victim soul she has to do it and it's beautiful to
see her at the very beginning where she she's terrified she doesn't know what to
do and in the end he actually shows her what to do and she says how you can go
off she says to them you know it's wonderful but yeah it's it's one of the
big big lessons at this stage now the Lord is telling us that struggles are
good for us we don't like them do we and we don't like facing a hurdle that we
think we can't take and we don't like failing and all of this kind of stuff
but he actually says it's very good for you because that's where you make your
decisions that's where you decide whether you're going forward whether
you're going to climb this mountain or not even with the cotton knees and the
injured ankle and the this and the other you're still going it's fantastic your
your inner core begins to be strengthened and begins to decide and another thing
that I read today was you won't get to heaven unless you decide that you really
wanted to go and if you really want to go you'll decide yeah you'll pay the
price to get there there is a price and it's overcoming yourself and overcoming
these struggles and letting the Lord really do what he wants and your place in
heaven determines that as well I remember quite a number of people saying to me
abitral going to have by the skin of my teeth as that's an insult to God because
his grace is totally sufficient to bring you to the absolute fullness totally
sufficient and who needs to be in a traffic jam at the gate anyway so we
can misunderstand things like that so he says that the struggle is actually
good for us and remember the book of Job Louise is going to have to remember
that the job was doing absolutely fine I had a good relationship with God and
then all hell broke loose and he had to learn how to respond to disaster in his
life and he was doing grand by himself God has given God has taken away
blessed be the Lord and then the temptation came through his wife to go
and curse God so that they the struggles can come through your
relationships as well and actually in fact a lot do and so he had to learn how
to handle that as well and then the most awful thing that happened to Job quite
apart from the disasters in his family were the three counselors that came to
and twisted them up and not and they brought him to the point of rejecting
God perfectly incredible and so in order to get through the crisis Job needed a
new experience of God and the experience that God gave Job I'm
giving you this to help you with Louisa the experience that God gave to Job was
to take him out of these circumstances bring him to the beginning of creation
and he said to him where were you when I created the morning
where were you when I told the sea thus far and no further and he brought him
through the whole of creation and and when Job had his his soul lifted up
to God's level to see things from God's level he said
I repent and sackcloth and ashes and the Lord said I give you everything back now
because they're safe in your hands now riches are only safe in the hands of
somebody where riches won't destroy you success is only safe in the hands of
somebody where success won't destroy you and this is why the Lord has got to
bring us in in Louisa's writings and to other
saints he says I have to put them in a place of safety
that is that whatever you have or whatever happens to you
it's not going to throw you it's not going to cost you your relationship with God
it's not going to cost you your heaven so the struggles are actually quite
important I don't know about you when I was going through lots of stuff I thought
of some radically wrong with me that I was the only one struggling on the
planet because people give you the impression because nowadays
got to put this professional front arm you're the successful you're the
perfect you're the this that's totally amazing
that's absolutely untrue and all the the struggles are the stars you get
in your crown so if you struggle to gain a crown in patience
that crown will be on your head in heaven forever
you'll have shown that aspect of God to to people forever and ever
in one of the higher volumes twice Jesus goes it says to Louis I'm going to
show you something you're going to learn something new about God today
and what he does is goes into heaven and he brings Aloysius Gonzaga
to meet her he died at the age of 19 he was a
novice in the Jesuit order and he died during some kind of a plague in
Rome and Jesus said to Louisa this man has loved me more than a vast
majority of the human race and so he glows with the the greatest
attribute of God which is love now he did it twice which is absolutely
amazing that's when you tiny bit I'm not telling you all that he said to her
just to show you that something you struggle with that's your crown
that's your glory afterwards so struggling is fine I hope I
liberated you and it's through the struggle that you gain
not only grace and victory but you also gain virtues
and you get to know the Lord much better as well
so he said I I need to put I want to put you into the middle of demons now he
really means it I will give them the freedom to torment you
and tempt you now notice that demons are not free to do what they like
they're only allowed to do what God permits
but the impression you would get if you've ever looked at the occult
or anybody remotely involved in the occult is that
there are two gods you know what I mean there's there's Satan and there's
God and the Satan is all this power and all the rest of it
they don't realize that Satan is the dog on the leash
and that he's destined for a terrible destiny
so I will give them the freedom to torment you and to tempt you
there's nothing wrong with temptation there's only there's only something
wrong with sin so that after you have fought
now my book has a wrong sentence here I hope yours is right
after you have fought the vices with the virtues is that correct
virtues you know yes no that's that's theologically
wrong so I didn't know they'd put the mistake into your book as well
after you have fought the vices knock out virtues
after you have fought the vices with the opposite virtues
so you have to fight anger with serenity
you've got to fight impatience with patience so you fight the vice with the
virtue and you gain the virtue I'm surprised they put that mistake
into your one as well you may already find yourself in
possession of those very virtues that you think you're losing
the very struggle gives it here and then your soul purged
embellished enriched will be like a king returning victorious from the most
fierce war who while he thought he would lose what he
possessed comes back more glorious and filled with immense
riches now first of all I want to give you Matthew
for and Luke for not giving you verses because you get the temptation of Christ
given to you in both so that even he had to face the demons
and be tempted by them as well I want to give you a revelation
chapter two revelation chapter two verse 11
verse 17 and verse 25 now in all of those verses the
Lord is saying if you overcome I will give you the crown of life
if you overcome I will let you into heaven if you overcome I will do this
in other words you've got to do the battle you've got a battle evil on the
earth in order to do this and then Jesus says to
Louisa after you've battled with them then I will come
I will form my dwelling in you and we will always be together
in other words Louisa has got to do this before
she's fit to have this new stage of union with God
it's true that your state will be painful the demons will give you no more
peace either day or night have you read the story of John Viani
yes he's fantastic the demons use to torment him
every night and one of the stories of John Viani is that he said to the
Satan one night you're a terrible bore he said to Satan
now you don't tell Satan that because he's pride and arrogance and you don't
tell him he's a bore so Satan said what do you mean
he says you do the same thing all the time and Satan said but it works
another time when Satan actually put his mattress on fire I saw the mattress
and I saw the fire marks he's one of the few saints I went looking for
he looked up and he said ask just you and he turned over with the mattress on fire
now Louisa's going to learn that Satan's name is pride and arrogance
the thing that pride cannot tolerate is to be ignored
and Louisa's going to learn the hard way that if you simply walk away from him
and pay no attention to him and treat him as if he's not fit of any
attention he will go away because he can't tolerate it
that's not the usual way you hear about dealing with Satan is it
Patrick Pio dealt had to deal with the demons at night as well there's one
wonderful story about him where the community discovered he hadn't got up
for prayer and they went to see what was wrong and he was lying in the pool of
blood on the floor but there was a lovely blue pillow under his head
that hadn't been on the earth before the night before
and they realized her blessed mother had put her there
yeah so they'll give you no peace day or night that is until the lord decides
that this battle is over and they'll always be in the act of waging a most
fierce war against you but you always keep your aim your focus
on what I want to make of you that is making you similar to me
and at the fact that you will not be able to arrive at this other than by
means of many and great tribulations now that's act 14 22
Saint Paul told all the early Christians you can't
get to union with God without going through many tribulations
but if you also write down Romans 8 29
that God wants us to be an image of Christ so that's why we have to go
through all of these trials and temptations
now we're going to the the battle I have to do the battle tonight get
it behind us and reading the Old Testament is actually a great help
essential reading this and saying oh I don't like this
so I want to give you Joshua chapter 5 verses 14 and 15
Joshua was a man who really battled in union with God
to accomplish God's will on earth Joshua JOSH
chapter 5 14 and 15
and what Joshua learned was that he saw an angel
and the angel said I'm actually the captain
of God's army Joshua said that's absolutely fine by me
I don't mind having a captain I can't see so long as you're there
and he only saw it just once and God worked incredible miracles you know
Joshua was the one who said to the Lord don't let the sun go down I need a few
more hours to finish this battle and the sun stood still
only two people had that who's the other one
Isaiah do you remember the shadow going on the steps of Hezekiah's palace
so here we are who could tell how frightened I don't get
Louise is only a teenager at this stage now frightened I was at such an
announcement I felt my blood freeze my girl
my imagination full of black ghosts now she's she's Italian she's very
imaginative and if you let your imagination
run riot on a problem you have two problems
and one of them is the imagination so I let my imagination full of
black ghosts and it seemed they all wanted to power me alive it seems to me
that before putting me in that painful state the lord gave freedom to
everything I was to suffer with God's in control notice he gave
freedom to notice that have you ever felt
that you went through a period when every party seems to be getting at you
this is get at Francis time do you know what I mean
that's actually a very important time because the Lord has put you on trial
and what you should do is testing testing to remind yourself
that that getting through this trial is very important instead of having a
problem with the people who are criticizing and condemning you and
all the rest of it because that's what the focus on the wrong thing
if we put focus on the fact that the Lord has put me into this and I must win
this battle then we'd get there much quicker
so I turned to him and I said Lord have pity on me or please
do not leave me alone and abandoned I see the rage of the demons as such
that they will leave not even the dust of of myself
how shall I be able to resist them my misery is well known to you
my misery means the all the human weaknesses
and you also know how bad I am that that's only
her saying that I can't correspond to the level of grace I'm given
therefore give me new grace that I may not offend you
my lord the pain that most torments my soul is to see that you too
must leave me that's Sam 22 verse one my god my god
why have you forsaken me but of course if Jesus was there the demons would turn
up to torment her would they so he has to go
add to whom shall I say a word anymore who will teach me
however may your will be always done that is the important thing
as John 14 15 and verse 23 as well
John 14 verse 15 and verse 23
now what Louisa has to realize is that you will never be tempted beyond your
strength that's Exodus 15 too you'll never be
nested beyond your strength so he kindly continued to say
do not afflict yourself so much know that I will never allow them to tempt you
beyond your strength that's also one Corinthians 10 13
one Corinthians 10 13 if I allowed this it is for your
good now beside that put Sam 145 verse 17
God only ever acts out of love God is love he can't act any other way
so it's for your good I never put souls in battle so that they may perish
first I measure their strengths there should be no s on that
I give them my grace and then I put them in that's like saying
you're not put into a course in school she can't handle
you're put into a course that actually suits you
and if some souls fall it's because they do not remain united with me now
that's the lesson for us is to stay close to the Lord
they don't remain united with me by means of prayer
no longer feeling the sensitivity of my love they go begging for love from
creatures in other words your focus changes
from turning to the Lord for strength and power
to human beings just simply looking for consolation
while I alone can satiate the human heart they do not allow themselves to be
guided by the path of obedience that's obedience to
God's will but in Louise's case it's obedience to her
spiritual directors as well believing more in their judgment than in those
who guide them in my place now for the very
tough life that Louise is being called to obedience was going to keep her on the
straight and narrow so what is the wonder that they fall
therefore what I recommend to you is prayer
even if you should suffer the pains of death you must never neglect that which
you are doing Luke 21 36 I think it is even more
the more you see yourself in the abyss the more
you will invoke the help of the one who can free you Luke 22 44
to the more trouble you have the more you call on him
still more I want you to place yourself blindly in the hands of the
confessor in other words don't do the rationalizing
that people want to do without examining what is being said
to you you will be surrounded by darkness
because of the demons are around you it's only darkness
and you will be the one who has no eyes and who needs a hand to guide her
the eye for you will be the voice of the confessor which like light
will clear the darkness from you the hand will be obedience
which will be your guide and support to make you reach a safe harbor
the last thing I recommend for you is courage
now in the Bible that's called fearlessness
being bold being brave okay I want to give you some
scriptures for that Deuteronomy 31
verses 6 to 7 Deuteronomy 31 verses 6 to 7
Sam 27 14 and Sam 31 verse 24
now if you actually do look up the scriptures you'll find they do enlighten
the text because they actually feed into each other
so the thing that the adversary the army fears the most is to see courage
and strength and the way in which one challenges the most dangerous fights
without fearing anything now that is true even on a human level
that the enemy fears the opposite being literally fearless
they actually fear that so beside that I want you to put
Sam 27 verses 1 to 3
with the Lord on my side who can be against me
Sam 118 verse 6 so that's what the demons are like
there's nothing they fear more than a courageous soul who is clinging to me
now it's the clinging to Jesus that they're they're more afraid of why
because they can't get at the soul because the soul is clinging to Jesus
and they're clinging to Jesus with a strong spirit
a soul that goes into their midst not to be wounded
but with the firm resolution of wounding them and exterminating them
now louisa will get to that point but not initially
the demons are frightened and terrified and would rather flee watch this now
this is a real insight that you need
but they cannot because they are bound by my will
it is God who is allowing the demons to attack louisa
if he's telling her that if she gives the correct response to them
they would want to flee but he's not going to let them flee
so she will inflict huge damage on hell
they see that there's much more to the battle than you think
they won't be able to flee because they're bound to my will
and they are forced to stay to their greater torment
therefore do not fear them now if that happens you see the demons will be very
wary of her in the future and eventually they will abandon her
altogether this in no no no it's no point
will only suffer if we go near her therefore do not fear them
he said and of course what's our problem we fear them
or they can do nothing to you without my will
and then when i see that you can no longer resist because you're about to fail
if you are faithful to me i will come immediately
and i will put everything to flight and i will give you grace and strength
courage then courage so i want to illustrate that by a story that
something that happened to me as a child i remember coming out of the house where
we were living and there was this huge snarling
dog challenging me and i was
mortally terrified and i just absolutely froze in front of the animal
i couldn't do a thing and of course that was the thing that encourages the
animal to attack once they see fear in you
they get the courage to attack and so it seemed as if i was standing there for
and i was only maybe five or six and it seemed as if i was standing there
forever and in what appeared to be the distance
i heard my father's voice saying i'm coming it's all right i'm coming
and he came up behind me and he picked me up from the back
and just turned me around in his arms you see
instantly i said to the dog you can go away now
now that actually happened the dog actually went away
that's what jesus saying to louisa because
you're safe i was safe in my father's arms i was also much higher up from the
dog of course as well but it was it was handy that my dad was six feet tall
and but it was the fact that once all fear went away from me the dog had no
reason to attack and that's exactly what louisa's being told
i don't want to actually read the battle because we wouldn't go far enough so
we'll do that next week so i leave it there for tonight so
we can have a little discussion together